the Hellboy trailer has just been
released and whilst the reception hasn't
exactly been hotter than hell's fire
that doesn't mean that there isn't a lot
to impact from the film's first look
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the movies Easter eggs plot
reveals and more so there will of course
be heavy spoilers if you don't want to
know anything going into the movie and
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it
so you don't have to the first thing to
take from the Hellboy trailer is that
it's a nod to the forever war in the
trailer we see two figures in a dimly
lit cave discussing the forever war it's
also mentioned how whoever battles in it
will need a strong right hand which is
of course and not towel boy himself but
Hellboy will need more than just his
hand and the trailer heavily teases
xcalibur the mythical sword from King
Arthur Hellboy has used the sword
several times in the comics mainly
against the Blood Queen who in this film
is played by Mila Jovovich ian mcshane
appears in the trailer and the actor is
playing the part of professor broom
broom is the BPRD member who first
discovered Hellboy and basically became
his father raising him and training him
those familiar with the previous Hellboy
film franchise will remember that the
character was originally played by John
who in those films and it's great to see
his inclusion here but what is the BPRD
well the bureau for paranormal research
and defense is the covert operation the
Hellboy works for and it too features
heavily in the trailer it's clear that
most of the movie will take place in
London and this is where the BPRD is
based however we also see an Alpine
location for the BPRD so maybe there
will be more than just the City of
London as a location the BPRD have
pretty much made Hellboy into a weapon
and have equipped him with his big gun
big baby which also appears in the
trailer fans of The Witcher 3 will be
familiar with the Wild Hunt but probably
don't know that they appear in Hellboy 2
in the trailer we see them riding
horseback this group is taken directly
from myth and legend and in the comic
books is overseen by the acerous Club
the acerous Club to make an appearance
in the trailer and it seems likely that
they are working alongside the BPO
we are also given a vision of hell when
Hellboy crashes an elevator it's unknown
how much this location will feature but
obviously it's pretty prominently tied
to the characters origins here we see
several demons including a giant bat
that seems to be quite prominent as one
of the movie's main villains in the
trailer we also get an image of Hellboy
wearing the apocalypse crown this crown
is a demonic artifact that converts the
power to become the biblical Beast of
the apocalypse that brings about the end
of the world and accordance with the
prophecy of the Book of Revelations the
queen of blood needs this in order to
free hog drew jihad a dragon prophesized
to destroy the world and this is why she
murders you've arrived just in time
during the trailer it's pretty clear
that she may even managed to get Hellboy
on her side at some point since most of
the world seems to hate him and this
would be an awesome plot point for the
film so what are your thoughts on the
Hellboy trailer did you have fun with it
and is there anything that I missed
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my review of the trailer
which we linked at the end of this one
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]